[Música]
el gobernador del estado de Florida
ronda santys cumplió los pronósticos y
renovó su mandato con una amplia
Victoria sobre el demócrata Charlie
christen santis que podría presentarse a
las generales de 2024 dijo que Florida
se convirtió en la tierra prometida Bajo
su mandato
también habló Donald Trump desde su
residencia de Mara lago Desde allí se
congratuló por los éxitos de algunos
candidatos republicanos y se vio un
Trump más calmado y menos incendiario de
lo que acostumbra
durante las primeras jornadas de la
Cumbre por el clima la co-27 tan solo
Nicolás maduro y Gustavo Petro han sido
las voces representantes de América
Latina en francés 24 pudimos hablar con
el mandatario colombiano quien dio sus
impresiones sobre la Cumbre
Bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo
dedicado a las principales noticias del
continente americano Mi nombre es
Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos esta emisión en
Estados Unidos en donde ya comenzaron a
salir los primeros resultados de las
elecciones de medio término uno de los
primeros resultados llegaba desde
Florida en donde se cumplieron los
pronósticos y el gobernador republicano
ron de santis renovó mandato con un
amplio margen sobre su rival demócrata
Charlie Christ de santis posible rival
de Donald Trump para liderar al partido
republicano en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 habló tras su
Victoria hizo un repaso a lo que han
sido las políticas de su mandato y atacó
duramente a la política progresista que
llevó según él a que muchos
estadounidenses se mudaran a Florida
[Aplausos]
ahora este gran Éxodo estadounidenses
para aquellas personas Florida para
tantos de ellos ha servido como la
tierra prometida nosotros
Nosotros hemos aceptado la libertad
hemos mantenido la ley y el orden hemos
protegido los derechos de los padres
hemos respetado a nuestros
contribuyentes y rechazamos la ideología
progresista
sobre el Día de votación y los primeros
resultados en conocerse habló también
Donald Trump desde su residencia de mar
a lago Desde allí se congratuló por los
éxitos de algunos candidatos
republicanos especialmente de Marco
Rubio quien también consiguió renovar el
escaño en el senado por el estado de
Florida se vio un Trump más calmado y
menos incendiario de lo que acostumbra
Más allá de las elecciones de medio
término la campaña ha servido para que
el expresidente libre una doble batalla
la de mantener la acusación de que le
robaron las elecciones pero también otra
a nivel interno menospreciando a
posibles rivales como el renovado
gobernador de Florida ron de santis más
detalles con lluis Muñoz
muchos republicanos siguen acudiendo a
las urnas por él soy republicana porque
quiero que comiencen a dirigir este país
como un negocio como liso Trump de
acuerdo pónganos de nuevo en marcha por
favor Aunque algunos ya no lo tienen tan
claro
republicana soy 100% republicana porque
amo este país No importa quién sea el
presidente Para mí Trump amo a Trump
pero voto más para salvar este país
el ex presidente Mientras tanto se ha
gustado en la campaña de las elecciones
de medio término muy participativo y
realizando una de sus aficiones
favoritas atacar al presidente joeyden
él es un enemigo del Estado quieren
saber la verdad el enemigo del estado es
él y el grupo que lo controla
pero no deja de poner su mirada en las
elecciones de 2024
[Aplausos]
voy a hacer un gran anuncio el martes 15
de noviembre en mara lago en Palm Beach
Florida
[Música]
y Es que además de luchar contra los
demócratas Trump también Libra su propia
guerra interna en el seno de los
republicanos y en plena campaña se ha
inventado un apodo despectivo incluso
para su principal rival el gobernador de
Florida ron de santis
estamos ganando grande grande en la
nominación del partido republicano como
no lo ha hecho nadie antes vamos a ver
aquí está Trump en 71 ron de
sanctimonius en un 10%
de santín no suele rendir reverencia a
Trump ya estás haciendo mítines de
campaña como un presidenciable ya ha
recaudado 200 millones de dólares para
su candidatura y se ha negado a
reconocer que buscará reelegirse como
gobernador está aprovechando la
coyuntura con un Donald Trump con
investigaciones judiciales por los
documentos secretos encontrados en su
residencia de Florida además de la que
se lleva a cabo por su influencia en el
asalto al Capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 cuando se negó a reconocer los
resultados que dieron la presidencia su
rival Joe biden esto ha dividido al
partido republicano con voces que
cuestionan las constantes polémicas del
ex presidente
por su parte el partido demócrata logró
una simbólica victoria en el gobierno
del estado de Nueva York que al ganar su
candidata Katy oshill actual gobernadora
en una competición con el republicano
liselding que parecía mucho más ajustada
durante la campaña en Massachusetts la
también demócrata Maura gili se
convirtió en la primera mujer lgbtiq más
en convertirse en gobernadora
y en la Cumbre de la co-27 la presencia
de los presidentes latinoamericanos
todavía no ha sido muy amplia por el
momento tan solo Nicolás Maduro
presidente de Venezuela y el mandatario
colombiano Gustavo Petro han sido
protagonistas nuestra enviada especial a
la Cumbre María Clara calle estuvo con
el dirigente colombiano y nos da más
detalles
en esta Cumbre africana como muchos la
Llaman por realizarse en Egipto los
presidentes latinoamericanos todavía no
han tenido mucha presencia Y es que en
la Cumbre los únicos en hablar de la
región han sido Gustavo Petro de
Colombia y Nicolás Maduro de Venezuela
Petro propuso un decálogo en el que
reiteró la idea que tiene de que se
pague la deuda internacional con
inversión en adaptación y mitigación
pero que tanto acogida ha tenido esto en
la cop 27 nos lo explicó en France 24
digamos poca en el escenario de poder de
la Copa
pero yo creo que es la única propuesta
lógica que hoy podríamos tener si
queremos financiar a gran escala y de
verdad
la adaptación al cambio climático que es
el tema de esta copa y la mitigación
el mecanismo que se propone que es
endeudarnos más así las tasas de interés
sean más bajas no es sostenible no es
posible que los países en desarrollo ya
sobre endeudados
aumenten aún más su deuda para financiar
una serie de obras y proyectos de las
cuales realmente las sociedades en
desarrollo no son responsables porque es
el efecto somos Víctimas de quienes por
conservar altos niveles de vida
están consumiendo excesivamente carbón y
petróleo y provocando la crisis
climática y justamente mientras se
desarrolla la co-27 en frase 24 les
presentamos una serie de informes
especiales a propósito de esta Cumbre
por el clima en este informe les
hablamos del Río Colorado que sufre por
la contaminación y la explotación
agrícola
en el valle Mexicali Baja California
predomina un paisaje árido
antes era un lugar lleno de agua y de
vida con la llegada del delta del Río
Colorado
Alfonso tambo es el gobernador de los
Cucapá una etnia que se asentó aquí hace
500 años recuerda su viejo caudal río me
trae recuerdos de nuestros antepasados y
pues mis padres también iban a pescar y
todos al río Colorado
es una ecologista que ha sido testigo
del daño en la zona provocado por el
cambio climático la sobreexplotación
para uso agrícola y la contaminación la
parte que vemos aquí en esta zona era
por donde pasaba el río Colorado
actualmente tenemos una zona muy
degradada del Río en donde vemos
principalmente pinos Salado y no vemos
agua superficial
al otro lado de la frontera en Estados
Unidos el río nace en Colorado y su
caudal de 2.200 kilómetros beneficia a
más de 40 millones de personas de los
dos países
desde el aire la piloto Stephanie Wells
anotado los considerables cambios en la
corriente del caudal del río
me siento culpable porque durante muchas
décadas de Estados Unidos ha tomado todo
el agua del río Colorado antes de que
llega a México
para revertir el daño desde Estados
Unidos y México brotan las iniciativas
una puesta binacional son los flujos
pulso que se liberan de las presas entre
mayo y septiembre gracias a estos del
río partido en dos vuelve a conectarse
Alejandro rosas es hidrólogo de sonoran
instituto y explica los beneficios de
este entrelazamiento al llegar la marea
y interceptar el río
genera también unas condiciones de agua
salobres que también benefician a
especies que requieren de estas
condiciones para subsistir a la parte
esta iniciativa voluntarios y
organizaciones se han dado la tarea de
reforestar la zona
una lucha que ha pasado desde el campo
hasta el arte
Karina es poeta hace un llamado a la
conservación a su manera y pues a mí me
surgen un poco las letras y creo que es
la oportunidad de poder ese plasmar lo
mis sentimientos hacia esa tristeza que
tenemos los esfuerzos binacionales no
revertirán de un día para el otro el
grave daño que toca el río
pero han logrado despertar conciencia
entre los habitantes de ambos lados de
la frontera hasta que las noticias sigan
conectados
[Música]